Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Alex from
San Diego.
Alex, you're on the air.
Speaker 6: Oh, hello.
I didn't actually expect to be chosen, so
I have a I have a question for you.
Yeah, I've long thought that the most important
issue in politics today is the impact that
money has on politics and that if you saw
that a lot of the other issues would naturally
solve themselves over time as people's natural
instincts are very reasonable in general.
Do you do you agree that this is the most
important issue or do you see something else
is the most important issue today?
Speaker 1: I believe that there is a sort
of triumvirate or a three headed monster of
sorts that are really the three most important
issues systemically.
And you hit on one of them money.
And politics is one aspect of this.
Climate change is a sort of systemic and structural
issue where if cities end up underwater, it's
not going to really matter what our opinion
about abortion is.
So it's sort of like whatever issue you care
about, if we don't deal with climate change,
we're not going to be able to to get that
fixed.
And then thirdly would be how our elections
are run, meaning that they're mostly first
past the post and and for the presidency.
It's an electoral college system.
So all those three issues together, if we
could fix campaign finance money in politics,
if we could get to some kind of transferable
vote and get rid of the Electoral College,
and then if we could deal with climate change,
then we would sort of be set up to start dealing
with, like, OK, I care about education.
Here's how I'll be an activist on education.
You might care about, you know, trans rights.
Here's how you can get involved in that.
I think that you are right in identifying
one of the three major issues.
Speaker 6: So that's kind of my point, though,
I feel like a lot of those other issues can
in many ways be reduced down to the money
and politics issue like climate change, for
example, if money and if money, if there was
some way to resolve campaign finance, then
over time, candidates would begin to more
accurately represent the will of the people.
Hopefully, ideally.
And most people want to do something about
climate change.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't disagree in that.
You're saying that over the long term that
we might get to some kind of equilibrium,
but it would be a long time because even if
you dealt with money in politics, fossil fuels
are still advantaged in a number of different
ways, including by the sheer market power
that they have in ways that are not directly
connected to money in politics.
So I'm with you about the long term.
I think if we wanted to more quickly do something
about it, I would still put these three issues
sort of as the the three headed monster that
needs to be dealt with.
Speaker 6: I see very and thank you for that.
I have one other very minor thing if you don't.
Right.
The other thing is I've I've had this idea
and I don't know if anyone else has talked
about it and I've heard it talked about, but
it's related to like how to address worker
executive pay disparity.
What an addition to also being able to increase
taxes on very wealthy people and, you know,
and wealth in general.
And I realize this idea may not maybe unpassable,
but nonetheless, I want to know what you think
of it.
Why not tie the tax rate for corporations
to the OP, to the difference between, like
the highest paid executives and the median
pay of a company, such that the bigger that
disparity, the more the company pays and some
additional tax.
And if they want to reduce that tax, they
have to improve average worker pay.
Speaker 1: It's a super interesting idea.
And so to give an example, the way it might
work would be if you if the CEO earns a hundred
times more than the lowest paid person, you
pay a 12 percent corporate tax rate.
But if the CEO earns a thousand times that
of the lowest paid person, your tax rate goes
up to 40 percent, something like that.
Right?
I mean, not those numbers, but that's the
idea.
Yeah, I think it's super interesting.
I think there's a couple problems.
One is I don't know how something like that
even comes close to passing, but let's let's
ignore that.
Right.
Because we're talking about whether it's a
good idea.
I think you still because the corporate tax
rate, first of all, applies only to certain
businesses.
Any Self Proprietorship, LLC s corporation,
those are passed through to the corporate
tax rate, doesn't even make a difference to
them unless you deal with that.
And the fact that you can still deduct and
loophole your way down to zero tax liability,
you would need to still combine it with an
alternative minimum tax for corporations.
You'd have to do a bunch of other stuff.
It's interesting, practically speaking, I
don't see any way that it would pass in the
next 20 years, but I think it's a really interesting
idea.
Speaker 6: OK, thank you for that.
That's all I have.
All right, good work.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much, guys.
This is week three of really strong phone
calls.
Really, really strong phone calls.
Not going to lie.
I'm we've really kind of hit a hit our stride,
I guess I would say.
Let's go to Chandler from Indianapolis, Chandler
from Indianapolis.
You're on the air.
Speaker 6: Hello, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, First-Time Caller,
long-Time listener.
Hate to be that cliche, thank you, but yeah,
so I just have a question about covid in general.
So I live in Indianapolis and just recently
the mask mandate was lifted for the city city
County Council lifted it on Monday night.
And something that really concerns me is that.
The percentage of the people who live in the
city who have gotten the vaccine, at least
like one shot, is only like I think I think
it's like 36 percentage, you know, less than
40 percent.
Yikes.
I'm not really sure what you would think.
For what?
Let me let me just rephrase.
So what would you think would be a reasonable
percentage for a massive mandate to be lifted
for a city?
You know, like the size of Indianapolis, I
don't know how it is with Boston or how it
is up there.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't you know, I'm not
an epidemiologist or an immunologist, so.
So basically I'm going by what I've read,
those experts say.
But it seems quite reasonable to me that as
you approach 50 percent immunized, that certainly
masks can start coming off and we're seeing
masks come off in most places and things seem
to be more or less going OK.
Among the vaccinated, the unvaccinated are
seeing increased hospitalizations in some
places like in Tennessee.
But I mean, I think at 50 percent you can
start to really do a lot of things.
Speaker 6: Oh, yeah, for sure, I would definitely
agree and honestly, at this point of the pandemic,
I would believe that.
You know, some things are kind of common sense,
like if you're going to go to Wal-Mart, I
would probably wear a mask if you were to
go out to a park, you know, don't wear a mask
unless there's like a crowd for whatever reason.
Yeah.
So.
Right.
I think that common sense would definitely
be.
Kind of what we all need to be listening for.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and remember that the CDC
has said that once you are vaccinated, essentially
every activity is low risk without a mask.
But certainly if there's a situation in which
you still would be more comfortable with a
mask, I say wear it.
Why not?
Speaker 6: Yeah, oh, yeah, for sure.
Yeah, and let me see.
Speaker 1: Well, that's all great, I'm going
to let you go because we have so many people,
but that's a great question and I'll hopefully
things will continue to improve in Indianapolis.
Speaker 6: I appreciate you taking the call.
All right.
Keep on doing what you're doing there.
Speaker 1: Very good.
Thank you so much.
Let's take a really quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we
are taking your calls momentarily.
Stay with us.